حذرناكم ولم تسمعوا وهذا ما ايديكم غضب
صيني من تايوان تؤكد نفاد صبرها لتعلن عن
اول اجراءات غزوه تايوان وبعد عاصفه تسرب
الوثائق الامريكيه هاهم اليوم يكشفون عن
الفاعل يضع شرطا للسلام ويعتذر للمسلمين
وامريكا ترفض طلب الدول الاوروبيه بضم
اوكرانيا فيما بوتين يتجه لايقاف اتفاق
الحبوب فهل تعود حرب البطون الخاويه
والمجنون يجري اختبار النووي تحت الماء
هذه المره والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تكتم انفاسها والعراق لتركيا عليكم
الاعتذار والتوقف عن ترويع الامنين واشنطن
تتحضر نوويا للرد على ايران والانتقام
الفلسطيني يشتعل من قلب تل ابيب ونتينياهو
يام بتعبئه جديده للجيش واليمن في طريقه
الى السلام الدائم بينما الاردن تشتبك
عسكريا مع اسرائيل لتعلن بعدها حاله
الطوارئ موسكو تصيب واشنطن في مقتل
لسانك حصانك انسونته صانك هكذا يقولها
العرب وفي الحرب ستكون معلوماتك وخططك
العسكريه هي ذلك الحصان وفي حال سقطت تلك
الخطط العسكريه في الحروب بيد العدو فذلك
يعني انك اصبحت كتابا مفتوحا امام عدوك
وقد يعني ذلك خساره مسبقه للحرب وان طالت
قليلا نعم وها نحن امام اهم واقوى مؤسسه
عسكريه في العالم انه البنتاجون الامريكي
وبعد ان فشل في الحفاظ على اسراره
العسكريه لتتدخل هذه المره وزاره العد
الامريكيه وتحقق في الامر الذي قد يدخل
الولايات المتحده في ازمه كبيره كانت فيه
عنها وبحسب فانه تم تسريب 100 وثيقه سريه
تتعلق بالامن القومي الامريكي وتوضح
بالتفصيل القدرات القتاليه لاوكرانيا
ونقاط الضعف المحتمله وجود النيت الواسعه
للمساعده في صد الغزو الروسي وملفات خاصه
بالشرق الاوسط والصين لتشكل هذه التسريبات
كابوسا عظيما ليس للولايات المتحده فقط
اللواتي يتبادلن المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
فيا لها من ضربه في مقتل للغربيين فمن ذا
الذي كشفها يجيب المسؤولون الامريكيون انه
من المرجح ان تكون روسيا او عناصر
الجاسوسيه مواليه لها ورات تلك التسريبات
وفق رويترز فيا له من سقوط مدون فان ذهبت
افلام جيمس بوند من هذا الفشل
الاستخباراتي
صحه المعلومات فقد وقعت بيد الدب الروسي
ليعلن حينها انتصاره بهذه الحرب فهل هي
معلومات صحيحه امنا هناك فخ في الامر وهنا
تتواصل الضربات الامريكيه لحليفتها
الاوكرانيه حيث ان الولايات المتحده تقاوم
جهود بعض الحلفاء الاوروبيين لمنح
اوكرانيا خارطه طريق لعضويه حلف النيتو
وذلك بقمه الحلف المقررات في يوليو المقبل
وفق صحيفه
ومن الحروب الدائره الى اصحاب العيون
الضيقه ونقصد بكين حيث اجتمع الرئيس
الصيني بنظيره الفرنسي هناك
ضروره توفير الظروف الواقعيه لتسويه ازمه
اوكرانيا سياسيا لكن مكون اتجه نحو الحديث
عن عدم جواز وضع اسلحه نوويه لدوله ما على
اراضي دوله اخرى في اشاره للاسلحه الروسيه
في بيلاروسي يرد عليه المتحدث الروسي بشكل
ساخر بقوله منذ فتره طويله لم نسمع مثل
هذه الانتقادات الشديده من الرئيس الفرنسي
تجاه الولايات المتحده اي ان امريكا تضع
اسلحتها في العديد من الدول فلماذا لم
تتكلم عن دايه ماغون وكما يقولها المثل
اليمني حقكم حق وحق اسمرك ياتي الدور على
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي عود الظهور مجددا
ولكن اين نعم لقد ظهر الى جوار الجنود
المسلمين وبعد ان احرق الجنود الاوكراني
كتاب المسلمين المقدس القران الكريم وكان
الزلمسكي يقدم الاعتذار لكن هل انتظرت كل
هذا الوقت يا هذا
المقدس للمسلمين ليقيم مادوبه افطار لهم
ويقوم بتكريم عدد من الضباط والجنود
المسلمين في الجيش الاوكراني
باستعاده شبه جزيره القرم واناء ما وصفه
بالاحتلال الروسي لها وهنا يؤكد الرئيس
الاوكراني على شرطه للسلام قائلا بانه ليس
له ولا لاوكرانيا بل ولا للعالم باسره
بديلا عن استعاده شبه جزيره القرم ولكن
مجلس الامن الروسي
ليرد على قائلا ان اوكرانيا ستزول من
الوجود فمن يصل لهدفه اولا برايكم ومن
المعارك الكلاميه الى حرب الغذاء حيث لوح
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالعمل
خارجان نطاق اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر موانئ البحر الاسود اذا لم
يتم تذليل العقبات امام مصادرات الروسيه
من الحبوب والاسمده محذرا الدول الغربيه
من ان اوكرانيا قد تضطر لتصدير الحبوب عن
طريق البر او الانهار الصين
ابدا باجراءات الغزو
انتهى وقت الكلام وحان وقت العمل التنين
الصيني يكشر عن انيابه تجاه الجزيره
التايوانيه هنا تؤكد الصين نفاد صبريات
تجاه جزيره تايوان وتنفذ تدريبات شبه
واقعيه على اليه غزو تايوان حيث اعلن
الجيش الصيني بدات تلك التدريبات العسكريه
لمده ثلاثه ايام في مضيق تايوان هذه
المناورات يتم التعامل بها قبل اي حرب كما
فعلت روسيا قبل غزو اوكرانيا لتركز تلك
التدريبات على هدف السيطره على البحر
والمجال الجوي والاعلام والتطويق الكامل
لتايوان حيث تاتي هذه المناورات الواقعيه
عقب عوده رئيسه تايوان من زياره للولايات
المتحده والتي لطالما حذر الصينيون منها
نعم اصحاب العيون الضيقه يعلنون ان وقت
المزاح قد انتهى وهي وزاره الدفاع
العنوانيه تعلن رصد احد وسبعين الطائره
وتسع سفن تابعه للجيش التحرير الشعبي
الصيني تقترب من الجزيره بشكل كبير وواضح
فهل يفعلها التنين الصيني
الاحداث والتطورات
اجرت كوريا الشماليه اختبارا جديدا على
غواصه هجوميه مسيره ذات قدرات نوويه في
احدث رد على المناورات الامريكيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه الغواصه النوويه اجره محاكاه تحت
المياه قطعت خلالها مسافه الف كيلو متر
وذلك بحسب وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه
شهدت عمليه الاغوار التي خلفت مقتل
جنديتين اسرائيليتين تفاعلا واسعا في
الوسط العربي اذ جاءت عمليه غور الاردن
ردا على الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على
المسجد الاقصى والمعتكفين من جهته اعترف
قائد في الجيش الاسرائيلي بفشل قوته في
ردع العمليه التي فرم من مكان الحادث لم
تنتهي العمليات هنا لننتقل الى قلب تل
ابيب هذه المره وذلك بعد ان تعرض
الاسرائيليون لعمليتي داس واطلاق نار خلفت
عده اصابات بينها حالات خطيره هناك اصدر
نت تعليمات للشرطه الاسرائيليه بتعبئه
جميع وحدات شرطه الحدود الاحتياطيه وامر
الجيش الاسرائيلي بتعبئه قوات اضافيه فهل
هي نار الانتقام العربيه اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه انها ارسلت الى الشرق الاوسط
الغواصه
التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه والمزوده
بصواريخ موجهه وذلك دعما للاسطول الخامس
الامريكي الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقرا له
كون الاداره الامريكيه تلقت معلومات تفيد
بان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات في المنطقه
قريبا وفق صحيفه
[موسيقى]
بالاعتداءات السافره لتركيا على اراضيه
وسيادته وطالبت بغداد انقره بتقديم اعتذار
رسمي والتخلي عن ترويع المدنيين بعد
الهجوم الذي استهدف مطار سليماني فلتعطيني
خدك كي اعطيك كفا وبعدها ساعتذر لك الا
تستحون يا هؤلاء والى اليمن حيث وصل
مبعوثون سعوديون وعمانيون الى العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء للتوصل الى اتفاق دائم لوقف
اطلاق النار مع الحوثيين وذلك قبل عيد
الفطر هذه المناقشات تركز على اعاده فتح
الموانئ والمطارات اليمنيه بالكامل ودفع
رواتب موظفي القطاع العام عمليه اعاده
الاعمار والانتقال السياسي الولايات
المتحده تسقط خططها من بين ايديها
ليستلقفها الدب الروسي فهل تعلن موسكو
النهايه بهذه التسريبات
[موسيقى]